[Music]
I genuinely believe that we've reached a
tipping point now in British policing
you can eat making up if we don't get
this right now it might be too late and
this does put people's lives at risk
Oscar x-ray zero six we do work harder
to do ours we are run ragged most of
time shove your hands it's really
devastating to see capable confident
passionate officers leaving the
organization because they've been
stretched too far
[Music]
in luton these officers are responding
to reports of a stabbing location across
the country almost every center of
population has had to grapple with a
sergeant knife crime here in Bedford
sure it's no different in fact the ratio
of knife offenses here is one of the
highest and the UK surpassed only by the
likes of London and the West Midlands
near the scene of this call armed
officers are getting up preparing to
confront the knife suspect who's inside
a nearby property this level of response
around 20 armed and unarmed officers is
common yet Bedford sure is funded as a
small rural force despite having many of
the problems of larger metropolitan
areas having sustained years of budget
cuts at a time of unprecedented demand
for its services Bedford sure police is
struggling its Chief Constable believes
it's now becoming unsustainable
everything at the moment morning noon
and night is Briggs it brings it brings
it but while we're trying to focus on
this over here which we need to and that
affects policing right under our noses
with our public services we are walking
towards a crisis and we have got to make
sure we address it and the police
service especially at this moment in
time is walking towards a cliff edge and
people aware of it we've now got to
start doing something about
at the scene of the stabbing the suspect
surrendered two armed officers and was
taken into custody another man was
treated for a knife injury to his arm in
which it this was just one of numerous
violent incidents our cameras captured
in a week of rear access to Bedfordshire
police no department off-limits from the
chief constable to the newest recruits
an insight into the decisions and that
compromises they're forced to make we
will discuss 3:05 in custody to
juveniles the daily morning meeting at
force headquarters is where senior staff
prioritized the operations requiring
resources it's Monday and day three of a
high priority investigation into a
missing vulnerable three-year-old boy
social services have got lord of with
regard to recovering the child and an
emergency protection order we can't
locate them up currently we've got three
Bedford debt addresses that have all
been checked over the weekend and a
London address all negative at this time
at the moment you do hello but from the
Child Protection Team at beds place is
it alright to come in for a moment
it's detectives from the child abuse and
vulnerable adults unit who are leading
on efforts to find the missing boy
as yet we've had no contact nor have
social services there's been a sim choir
is in London
with the natural father who says he
hasn't seen him for a year already more
than 30 officers have been involved in
this inquiry it's causing their strain
obviously because it's so resource
intensive in relation to conducting so
many different inquiries that we need to
do in order to find this missing child
in addition to managing our daily
workload for example we've got 18 live
investigations per officer roughly they
range from told offences to vulnerable
adult offenses and on one given day we
can be dealing with a financial fraud
against a vulnerable adult we could be
dealing with a shaken baby or a baby
that has suffered with broken bones or
even a child death so having to deal
with this it does take away from them
managing investigations this type of
safeguarding issue now accounts for a
huge part of Bedfordshire scarce Lord
most not criminal offenses but issues
around protecting the public from harm
okay the emergency is one of my friends
inside has been threatening his father
with knives in the kitchen today an
abusive behavior when you say today is
it now today I said right now right now
although the potential risk from a man
threatening others at knifepoint is high
for the officers attending this call
it's as much about ensuring that man
doesn't harm himself helping those
suffering from mental health issues has
become routine he's no no but he's had
to go his dad with budget cuts elsewhere
in the public sector increasingly these
officers are becoming the social workers
of last resort you need to calm down
listen are you gonna be alright stay
here tonight there is a reality that the
people that will always get called when
there is nowhere else to go will be the
police service and by way of example to
that you know we've seen our 999 calls
in what is a small rory funded county go
from in the late 200s a couple of years
ago to last year being around about 350
a day and this year that number has
regularly gone over 550 calls a day and
exceeded six hundred calls a day that
increase in demand is putting huge
strain on departments like the force
control room we were there as the chief
constable heard firsthand about the
impact that's having here recently
bedford sure had to suspend its 101
non-emergency telephone service for a
while because of huge demand and the
lack of resources it's difficult demand
is up everywhere this is a cross placing
not just in Bedfordshire at an annual
event bringing members of the force
together the chief acknowledge the
tremendous strain they're under we try
to get to everything and we try to do
everything but the reality is we cannot
do everything that I want us to do
and that you want us to do as quickly as
I was like us to do it and we all having
to make some difficult decisions about
pushing back around some areas in
Bedford forensics officers have been
called out to examine a murder scene 20
year-old Patrick Olynyk was shot and
killed here the night before the third
murder victim in this town in almost as
many weeks Bedford sure now pulls it's
major crime investigations with the
neighboring Cambridgeshire and
hartfordshire forces but the sergeant
violence is putting significant strain
on those detectives and their uniformed
colleagues often that comes at a price
in terms of having to draw officers who
are already working really hard to come
in on their rest days on overtime in
order to continue to provide a service
to the public in Bedfordshire it has
significant knock-on effects in terms of
organizational and personal resilience
once we're in there it will be all
occupants to be detained and then once
we've got control of the location we'll
look at doing a systematic search in
Leighton Buzzard their briefing officers
ahead of a raid on a house linked to the
county lines drugs trade a phenomenon
that seen big-city drugs gangs set up
supply routes into rural communities
please show me your hands
execute them issues to direct that
warrant in this location the two people
inside this flat will be treated as
victims vulnerable individuals have been
coerced into providing their property as
a base for the drugs gangs once you've
been searched I'll explain what's going
on and I'll have a chat with you because
obviously we're getting told somehow is
going on here you are a drug user
there's needles everywhere
so with you guys been to this address as
well it's day four in the hunt for the
missing three year old boy and more
inquiries in Bedford Luton and London
officers from other departments are
being drafted in to help a model now
commonplace in Bedford sure born out of
necessity so it's a bit like squeezing
the balloon I push this side to help
this side but that always leaves a
pressure there and it is effectively
often robbing Peter to pay Paul
it sounds unsustainable well it's no way
it's no way to keep her public safe
recently Bedford sure serious and
organised crime unit was forced to
suspend their investigations for a while
and reassign their detectives to deal
with a backlog of domestic violence
cases it's frustrating but you have to
look at what the need of the
organization is when you've got people
that have been assaulted and are living
in corrosive environments children being
brought up in corrosive environments
it's actually right that we put our
focus there the problem is if we only
put our focus there then we're not
focusing on the people that are
supplying the drugs that leads to drug
addiction which leads to people Bogle in
homes
we're not tackling the people that are
manufacturing and converting firearms
which end up in the hands of our young
people which involved in gang violence
and in firearms discharges in the
streets so you can only extrapolate so
far and eventually the crime and the
money behind organized crime resort
drives so much of the demand that we
suffer on a daily basis
coming up this isn't rocket science if
we haven't got the officers to do the
job that we need to do people will not
get the service that they need and I
genuinely believe that puts people at
risk
you
[Music]
Artie same car versus question
if you have to go to hospital you banged
your head the Lewton response team have
been called to help at the scene of a
road accident
a pedestrian knocked over by a car if
you don't stop okay the victim is
resisting attempts by the paramedics to
treat him the officers decide to follow
the ambulance to hospital an A&E for
three hours they're off the road
standing guard over a potentially
violent patient another example we found
of the stretch and resources because of
the emphasis on safeguarding
[Music]
couple three we approach the female and
asked if she wants to buy some cannabis
she refused they pulled a knife out her
PCE and Wilson is an 18-year veteran on
route to this knife incident in Bedford
he's on his own
x-ray 0-6 could just have a vehicle
check fewer resources have met many of
the response officers during the day a
single manned yeah so copy this if they
get into trouble back up could be some
distance away
yeah he got to treat it differently
really got a risk assess everything in
front of you if we do go to a domestic
for example or a violent instant
something else does usually come to back
you up but you initially feel there
before then you gotta deal with yourself
PC Wilson says he's never known morale
so law several of his colleagues have
already quit the job a fear my friends
have left two other things have gone to
different careers because they're
they've made a decision it's quite a big
decision to make
are the law days when you think you know
18 years is enough for me now time for
me to find her something else it is
getting more mannequins getting bit more
dangerous I believe so a couple of years
maybe I might changing across England
and Wales 22,000 police officer posts
have been shared since 2010 today
Bedford church Chief Constable is
visiting the latest intake of officers
the Forces recruiting again but only to
maintain current staffing levels which
at just over 1100 is around 20 percent
under the required strength you wanna
sign it as well once I've got the
answers here
among the new recruits PC Neil daddy out
in Bedford with a more experienced tutor
constable there to offer advice and help
says we're gonna be to give me a ticket
and we gonna be reporting you for twelve
and was disqualified okay among the
newer recruits
there is a recognition they're joining a
rapidly changing service but also a
determination to try to make it work I'm
hoping because we've got quite a few
recruits coming through they're going to
be trained up and I like V alleviate
some of that pressure but we will we
work and we do what we need to do in
order to get the job done and sometimes
that might be a case of taking on more
responsibilities or doing something that
we wouldn't be doing the day-to-day
basis well that's that's is part of the
job and I feel I so he goes over there
across the country budget cuts have
forced chief constables into
prioritizing certain areas of policing
criminal damage
low-level theft and antisocial behavior
among the areas receiving far fewer
resources it is a cause for tension
within many communities
John Belcher spends increasing amounts
of his time explaining and justifying
that shift in priorities yeah good
from your perspective any issues or
anything that I need to be aware of or
any concerns you've got at the moment
that I can help yeah use wireless has
been on the increase in particular in
central rewards it's been an issue who
have lost about three lives yeah I would
say actually for Bedford sure Luton gets
good policing when you take into account
the numbers we've got but it's still not
sufficient numbers that we should have
[Music]
seven days into the hunt for the missing
three-year-old boy he's finally found
safe and well this type of inquiry is
now commonplace a recategorize ation of
the risks especially relating to missing
children has seen a 90% increase in
missing persons inquiries case meditate
there's a guy in challenge Luton Town
Centre Janet Tucker another guy with me
holding a bleed where is it we're about
in the town centre centre right what my
daughter so far is basically China
attacking with a blade sticks out the
blue and for everyone that's okay
during a search of nearby streets in
central Luton the officers spot a young
man matching the description of their
knife suspect I'm just gonna cuff you
quickly because someone's
for several minutes this food cheese
continues to the point of exhaustion for
the officers and suspect still struck in
the face with in capacitance Bree other
officers managed to rugby tackle him in
the next Street pouch for the vehm
individual cannabis wraps which is fine
over the fence in a week embedded with
Bedford sure police listening to the way
in which senior officers are trying to
run under-resourced apartments it's
clear to me this force is struggling in
2015
Teresa may accused summon the police
service of crying wolf over their
warnings about the consequences of
budget cuts three years on those who
predicted a looming crisis say they've
been proved right this isn't rocket
science if we haven't got the officers
to do the job that we need to do people
will not get the service that they need
and we will be doing things in a way
that we don't want to do them so we'll
be rushing when the radio goes and these
officers are going from shout to shell
they're not spending the time problem
solving and I genuinely believe that
puts people at risk because we've got to
go to the next serious incident and by
the way don't be in any doubt and you
will have seen some of this we run out
of officers to do when I know Michaels
in luton another suspected knife
offender is off the streets the in
capacitance spree appears to have
rendered him unconscious he could be
faking it but they can't take any
chances an ambulance has been called he
was eventually checked over in hospital
and given the all-clear
three hours later three hours in which
some of these officers were off the road
unable to respond to the backlog of
other calls on a busy Friday night in
Luton